نعم، رأينا قبل شهرين أن
السفن الروسية أرادت سفينة روسية دخول
المنطقة التي تقع فيها حدائق طواحين الهواء الهولندية في
بحر الشمال
بهدف معرفة كيفية تشغيل هيكل التحكم المشترك
لمزارع طواحين الهواء هذه
بحيث يتم تشغيلها
كان هناك تهديد لذلك أرسلنا
البحرية وخفر السواحل لمرافقة هذه
السفينة الروسية ولذلك غادروا
المنطقة. كانت المرة الأولى التي نرى فيها
سفينة روسية تدخل منطقة
مزارع طواحين الهواء للقيام
بالاستطلاع، إنه أمر بالغ الأهمية  خطيرة للغاية
بالطبع ولكن في المجال السيبراني نرى
هجمات متعددة بشكل يومي تقريبًا
لاقتحام السفارات الهولندية أو
تجاه القوات المسلحة من أجل
مصلحتهم، لذا فهذه إحدى
وظائفنا هي التأكد من أنهم
لم تنجح في الطموح
نعم على البنية التحتية الحيوية في
هولندا